cela concerne aussi les jeunes mais dans
un autre domaine depuis le 1er janvier
les préservatifs masculins sont
désormais gratuits en pharmacie pour les
moins de 26 ans une autre catégorie de
jeunes une annonce du président de la
République Emmanuel Macron avec nous
pour en parler Jérôme André le directeur
d'achève prévention santé alors première
question comment est-ce qu'on fait pour
en bénéficier de ses préservatifs
gratuits c'est assez simple vous pouvez
donc vous rendre à partir du moment où
vous avez moins de 26 ans dans n'importe
quelle pharmacie et puis vous seront
proposés donc deux boîtes de
préservatifs soit les Eden soit les
Polaris donc il y a des marques les
polarises d'ailleurs c'est un côté
nostalgique aussi pour HF prévention
puisque c'est l'une des marques dont le
parrain est Christophe Dechavanne qui
pendant des années a réclamé à ce que le
préservatif soit gratuit faut croire
qu'effectivement Emmanuel Macron a
entendu puisque c'est lui qui a permis
notamment d'avoir un coup extrêmement
faible extrêmement bas pour justement
que les jeunes puissent avoir des
préservatif limite un peu gratuit il
était faire de lance de ça et le
président de la République a dû
l'entendre puisque les préservatifs
aujourd'hui sont complètement gratuits
en pharmacie pour les moins de 26 ans il
suffit d'avoir quand on a entre 18 et 26
ans une carte vitale et si vous n'avez
pas de carte vitale et que vous avez
moins de 18 ans vous avez le droit de
vous présenter en pharmacie on vous
remettra effectivement donc une boîte
les contours sont encore un peu floues
aujourd'hui puisque dans la
précipitation l'annonce des manuels
Macron a été faite mais il y a pas eu de
directives très clairs qui ont été
posées mais il semblerait que ce soit
une boîte par jour et donc comment
est-ce qu'on fait pour pour se faire
rembourser alors en fait on se fait pas
rembourser c'est à dire que simplement
on va en pharmacie on présente la carte
Vitale si on est majeur moins de 26 ans
si on est mineur on vous la remet comme
ça et ensuite on vous la remet et merci
au revoir les pharmaciens doivent
néanmoins avoir la possibilité de
pouvoir aussi expliquer aux jeunes et
avoir un peu un petit ent quelqu'un avec
eux notamment sur comment est-ce qu'on
pose le préservatif et que ça pourrait
effectivement
comment dire
déclencher un entretien de santé
sexuelle je suis pas convaincu
effectivement que ça fonctionne comme ça
c'est d'ailleurs le regret que nous on a
c'est que pourquoi les moins de 26 ans
là on voit dans le dispositif de la
boussole c'est les moins de 30 ans et
puis à chef prévention avait fait
d'ailleurs un plaidoyer auprès du
ministère de la Santé et d'Emmanuel
Macron parce qu'au départ c'était les
18-26 ans et ils ont ils n'inclué pas
donc les mineurs tout comme nous ce
qu'on dit aussi c'est que tout le monde
n'a pas de carte vitale et pourtant il
nous apparaît nécessaire de pouvoir
effectivement le donner d'une manière
très large cette réforme fait suite à
une réforme effectivement qu'il avait
déjà proposé il y a deux ans où on
pouvait effectivement aller chez son
médecin et demander une ordonnance pour
avoir deux boîtes par an félicitons nous
effectivement de cette nouvelle réforme
mais c'est pas suffisant parce qu'en
réalité on le voit et on le voit
d'autant plus à chaque prénom puisque
aujourd'hui on fait sur l'année donc
2022 qu'on vienne quitter on a réalisé
plus de 16000 dépistages du VIH et des
IST en université puisque effectivement
on travaille sur l'ensemble des
universités d'Île-de-France mais pas
seulement et en général vous le
connaissez bien permettrait peut-être de
faciliter ou en tout cas de ralentir
les maladies mais le problème de la
santé sexuelle c'est que c'est pas que
un problème d'outils c'est aussi un
problème de de discussion avec les gens
de pouvoir effectivement modifier les
comportements de nos jeunes aujourd'hui
il y a beaucoup de jeunes qui imaginent
que le préservatif c'est aussi quand on
leur dit mais est-ce que tu mets un
préservatif ils nous disent bah non
c'est bon ma copine en l'occurrence
prend la pilule donc je n'ai pas besoin
de mettre de préservatif or en réalité
le préservatif certes est un moyen de
contraception parmi tant d'autres mais
c'est aussi et avant tout un moyen de se
prémunir des infections sexuellement
transmissibles du virus du sida qui
malheureusement sont en plein boom nous
on le constate sur nos chiffres 16000
dépistages donc et j'ai sorti les
chiffres
Île-de-France et j'ai fait un focus sur
les Yvelines puisqu'on est dans le 7 8
et que ça nous intéresse on est à 64 %
d'IST sur chaque dépistage donc
rendez-vous compte à chaque fois qu'on
dépiste on dépiste des infections
sexuellement transmissibles donc il y a
une vraie urgence à pouvoir agir et sur
le fait d'élargir encore le préservatif
gratuit mais aussi les deux de pouvoir
permettre aux gens d'avoir de
l'information en santé sexuelle et comme
vous ne connaissez bien on a voulu
répondre ça avec effectivement plus de
300 professionnels de santé puisqu'on a
créé Sacha Sacha qui est la première
intelligence artificielle
conversationnelle et aujourd'hui ça
montre bien le besoin puisque Sacha
réalise 25 000 conversations chaque mois
chaque mois il y a effectivement 25000
conversations qui sont réalisées et là
on est vraiment dans de la haute couture
si je puis dire c'est un site de la
haute couture sur de la prévention
puisque Sacha répond vraiment aux
besoins des jeunes en matière donc de
prévention c'est ça qui sera intéressant
ça sera effectivement de démultiplier la
prévention le dépistage et pas seulement
de rendre un outil gratuit même si ça
reste nécessaire et alors la rédaction
de tv78 s'est rendu à la rencontre des
jeunes pour leur poser la question si
pour eux c'était une bonne chose la
gratuité des préservatifs les propos
recueillis par Patrick Jacques de
Dixmude et Ludivine canard j'ai entendu
parler sur les réseaux et je trouve ça
vraiment vraiment top parce que ça
permet à tous de se protéger de tes
enfants et également des maladies
vraiment je trouve que c'est une bonne
idée puis il y a des gens qui osent pas
forcément aller en acheter qui ont pas
l'argent ou enfin c'est tout con il y en
a leurs parents ils vérifient un peu
leur compte et bah du coup ils ont un
peu enfin ils ont pas très envie que
leurs parents le savent et donc ils
osent pas et donc ils prennent des
risques après ce que je vais l'utiliser
je sais pas ça va dépendre surtout bah
de la qualité de ce qu'ils vont donner
en soi mais comme c'est monsieur ouais
je pense c'est une très bonne chose pour
ceux qui ont pas les moyens de s'en
fournir et même pour les autres ça peut
faire des économies etc non je pense que
c'est bien parce que
peut-être il y a ce côté aussi un peu
tabou d'acheter des préservatifs en
magasin qui fait que potentiellement
certains seraient dans ce genre d'achat
on peut pas dire ah bah j'avais pas
d'argent j'en ai pas acheté on peut pas
on pourra pas il y a pas d'excuse
possible donc c'est une bonne chose
alors on vient de l'entendre les jeunes
sont plutôt contents mais la question du
prix a clairement un impact Jérôme la
question du prix un impact mais aussi le
lieu c'est à dire que en vrai et là on
le voit effectivement dans le
micro-trottoir il y a des jeunes qui
pensent que on va pouvoir le trouver
dans des magasins il aurait mieux valu
aussi permettre que quand on va dans une
grande surface ou une supérette et bien
qu'on puisse avoir ce dispositif de
gratuité n'importe où n'importe quand
c'est ça qui est ennuyeux c'est
qu'effectivement il ne faut pas donc
imaginer que tout le monde ira en
pharmacie pour pouvoir avoir des
préservatifs gratuits donc quid de
l'accès parce que effectivement donc
dans les supermarchés ça aurait été
intéressant quid effectivement de la
limite de l'âge pour le coup
26 ans c'est un peu dommage et puis pour
les gens qui n'ont pas de carte vitale
ça reste aussi dommageable et puis
encore une fois plus de discussions
l'éducation à la santé sexuelle ça doit
démarrer avec l'Éducation nationale
aujourd'hui c'est quand même malheureux
qu'en France il n'y ait que deux heures
qui soit donc mise à disposition
là-dessus à condition déjà qu'elle soit
faite et croyez-moi c'est pas le cas
partout notamment y compris en Île de
France et on se bat beaucoup avec la
région Île-de-France et notamment
Valérie Pécresse dans le cadre de
l'Île-de-France sensida pour permettre
qu'il y ait encore plus mais c'est pas
le cas encore aujourd'hui et on le voit
il y a vraiment donc des besoins sur les
modifications de comportement des gens
parce qu'aujourd'hui pour eux les
infections sexuellement transmissibles
c'est tout aussi invisible que le virus
du sida et ça pose des vrais problèmes
je le dis si vous ne vous faites pas
dépister d'une infection sexuellement
transmissible vous pouvez avoir des
vrais problèmes ça ne se voit pas et
vous pouvez avoir donc des concerts être
stériles etc etc et c'est bien
dommageable alors qu'en en fait on a un
arsenal qui permettrait de pouvoir
guérir puisque pour certaines infections
sexuellement transmissibles on guérit
merci beaucoup Jérôme André d'être venu
en parler avec nous je le rappelle vous
êtes le directeur d'achève prévention
santé